feature last week but thank you but it's
a game a bunch of us are playing last
week it's a bunch of fun Sean you played
as well I played it on the Sean method
your piece was a lot more thoughtful
than mine I really just shouted at the
sex demon yeah I ended that was behind
the camera okay I didn't put that at the
piece cuz I needed to you know maintain
an air of seriousness but it was all sex
demon on the back yeah so we've been
played a bunch of this I'm like I think
like unanimously none of us have like
ever managed to spare to like last
longer than four or five days like I've
seen I seem to be able to kill the
cannibals pretty good yeah with molotovs
yeah and I'm like 50 logs into building
my cabin and then just 20 of them turn
up yeah like and you had a lizard's to
eat yeah you trust are trying to eat
cannibals you become a cannibal slowly
throughout the game yeah it doesn't
allow you to eat people unfortunately
yes sir that's a future that needs to be
implemented I think well it's an alpha
at the moment so who knows what's going
to beat up you can eat people in beta
i'm calling it alright so let's jump in
I've got so Jeremy here you are so it's
your inventory i am gonna cook a lizard
because i'm planning on going a little
journey here and are you gonna do it at
night time are you gonna sleep until the
day no i am gonna throw that lizard in
the fire and take a little nap see we
have to get on that hopefully to become
day there you go look at that no
rightful streaming light why do
sometimes when i fell asleep it was
still denied side no I think you slept
through the entire day okay and you were
just a lazy bastard an yeah but as you
see I've spent the two hours before the
show constructing a perimeter I'm a
little baby good yeah I'm very long time
so too long to admit on the air well
that actually stopped them from coming
in you know I have not held off any sort
of siege against them okay in the
trailer I've seen them jump over entire
wall so I don't think that really a
point except for the illusion of
security which is the most importantly
all to the fact that you have actually
holy it was surreal in here yeah you
know only happened or but you're the
fire the fire stops them dead it's all
crap okay well they catch on fire don't
actually stop them oh well that's great
because then you just have a house full
of people on fire exactly which is
exactly what I've always wanted so we're
here on you know well there's no map so
we're here on a coast I don't know what
cardinal direction and we're just gonna
go for a little hike you know maybe find
some cannibals I don't really know
what's going to happen this is the
forest i do want to point out in my
experience one of the most powerful
weapons you can use in the game way is
the leg Sean I'm glad you
that because i took a pro tip out of
your book here and I grabbed a leg
before the stream started oh oh no oh
the leg is too powerful oh the leg is
opie throws the game well oh that's a
good game right there that's how we're
good we're good just a loading hitch
justjust you have no idea its direction
you're pointing loading is one of the
wonderful features in this alpha build
of the farce okay also you know before
we get too far Sean I found out a little
thing that I don't think you even know
everyone's much of this game you chopped
entries yeah well looked at to Danny but
I found out someone said you could climb
trees and I thought it was [ __ ] so I
just wanted to test it out and you can't
quite climb a tree but in excuse well
that settles it takes a long time to cut
down a tree in this game if you've ever
played this game you're a sick of
clicking your mouse button go all right
I knew sweet jumps off of trees and
that's pretty sick yeah the Pioneers
used to ride those things man I think
the countable can I think I saw it
snowed a tree yeah but you you just
hacked climb when you mash space button
as a tree falls alright so you start
this game in a plane crash we've decided
to make you walk from coast to coast
exactly so you start in that plane and
you come to in a cannibal is taking your
son will presumably your son it's just a
small boy yeah it could be any small boy
that you're hanging out with these
sleeping on your arm when you start the
game though so like I said any small be
any small boy only you two are on the
plan also worth noting that there's a
dead stewardess and your semi living
body on the plane and this cannibal
decides to take a small child I'm
longing to meet I'm an adult ladies and
on that chip I mean maybe it's like a
veal thing is tender but you have a
pedometer here and I'm repurposing it as
a pedo meter oh yeah in the woods
because they took my boy Oh need some
berries here are they okay for you there
no I never read the survival book about
berries on really care just eat berries
if they pop up you know maybe the poison
do you have the script of the Asian ones
are the ones that are like pairs of
berries you want like the big bunch oh
they got rid of my leg goodnight
you're not equipped alike yeah now I'm
not properly equip stupid oh you already
reached our coast you know it looks like
maybe I was on some sort of Peninsula
day I think maybe you need to turn right
heading a hard so there are usually
cannibals hanging out by this is this is
where you come doesn't this no no cuz
see I can't further down I somehow guys
there's always the homeowner on here and
so let's let's continue down the beach
here may well find a cave the good sex
demon in it and for people at home the
sex demons are just sort of these weird
they're not actually called sex demons
it's actually the cave entrance if you
lost it really yeah sweet Jesus let's go
some below yeah spelunking with a human
leg big enough sex demon right so this
is weird you go through the water and if
this is the Kaiba think oh yeah there
you just dry land all of a sudden yeah
alright as you as any of you managed to
actually murder this thing all the guys
on it and then no it's not but those are
just regular demons not sex demons get
it I get editor get out of that get out
of Energon isness we don't ever hang out
during the day 200 my ass whoa mama oh
alright well let's just let's continue a
lil hike here this is just a little i
can think i don't think they like you i
think it actually loads a separate world
when you go in there i think so too i'm
just gonna pretend that they're just
territorial though and that that's it oh
look at that dude he's dead body oh oh
oh god what's happening there I hacked
him apart with a leg am i holding us yes
I really look down again not again
another look straight yeah and then now
look down and don't hit anything it
looks like you got a leg for a dick haha
wait wait equipped ahead equip the hell
there you go yeah yeah yeahs this wait
wait wait now this is one scout here
look out into the sunset and now slowly
pen down a slow romantic moment oh hello
there hey there buddy oh are you doing
down there you just keep doing your you
keep doing what you're doing amazing you
landed on this island you don't have
anything but a flashlight Oh what I'm
I'm starving it out here yeah you know
only the essentials Dan you got pack
light when you're in a crash in a plane
sure ah the forest the forest you can do
it you can reach the other side of this
island I you know the other side I'm
gonna be honest with you as an invisible
wall but maybe we'll find something cool
on the wait
you that invisible it's not a bad the
destination is it it's the journey yeah
look at those toenails I didn't even
notice that oh that's nice oh sweet yeah
those are gross those are gross I think
if you spend as much time living in
caves you're telling us probably
wouldn't be as long as those are a
climbing implement oh what's that
there's yeah it's a weird visual glitch
that happened a lot to me too yeah like
slicing but it happens during the day
yeah exactly it's sort of just created
like weird blue towers for me when the
Lightning went off it didn't actually
load in the lightning yeah well not
mention the folks at home you have any
questions by all means I stick them in
the chat we'll get right to them ah next
next person you see I want you to beat
them up with a leg I'm just trying to
find trouble now man how how long have
you survived in the save file oh god I
don't even know because it doesn't tell
you the actual number of days til you
die because i think the cannibals get
more aggressive over time because there
they are like they're observant at first
they'll watch you from afar and as they
kind of like you see you you see a man
or is that over there i think straight
over there rosenfield I this is where I
tried to make my log cabin but then
realized that I'd built it very very
close to a encampment of actual oh oh
yeah well yeah Yelich but sometimes
they're not there then it's even
freakier yeah yeah that's the real scare
the ambience care have you seen any of
the M the tennis ball effigies uh this
ball everybody else was playing I think
was you that showed me actually it was a
i saw one where it was basically a bunch
of like bodies but like tennis rackets
through them like and they were dressed
up as tennis people like everyone else
on the flight was going to like some
tennis academy Federer man the hakama
part yeah I don't see any dudes at this
little villa this little dude village
well dude village the village of dudes
it's not the invisible wall over there
to the left is that where we're going oh
we can't wait for G over there on that
island oh right here yeah this little
thing right here I was looking too far
Oh delightful look at that's a human
head a lovely lady sure that's probably
not my son although his hair may have
grown since I last saw him take me well
I think you've managed to actually
circle the entire island I think so too
I don't see any cannibals pretty good I
like it that maybe this is the tactic
everyone's wanted to know about
because its affinity on twitch asks do
the cannibals respawn can you kill all
of them I have no idea I have killed a
lot of cannibals and they just keep
coming I don't think there's a finite
number on the island I think that
they're they're constantly voted in that
cave and they all knew cannibals yeah
and they have a quick asexual
reproduction cycle they don't y'all need
to bone man I mean that's all the sex
demon right there exactly that's are you
like destroying this footage because
you're carrying the foot you know I
think that is just my naturally sharp
torso eglington asks can you chew on the
toenails for extra health I hope so God
where are all these cannibals man it's
just the forest nine what's going on
just the forest so they've patched it
apparently and they orbited accountable
well they do have a vegan mode which is
you can just load in and there are no
cannibals is that a real thing yeah that
is a real thing I swear no honestly i
swear to god totally bit i would not do
that to you Danny not on the air you
were like this that's amazing oh go to
an open play go to an open area right
I'm gonna keep keep hunting for the
cannibals man I'm not stopping this
dream intimacy area decibel here's an
open area to see some on ominous
lightning my voice see the thing is I'm
playing this game every single time I
want to see a cowboy I see God dog oh me
too that's why i'm so confused its like
none of them here it's like I think Sean
might provide a thing they all might be
boning in that cave yeah I think so too
i slept multiple days in anticipation
and finding some cannibals oh that was a
party to jump there young looking like
so you can like can you kick flip can
you do a hardflip i think that's in
version 3 i guess this is version free
version point oh three mr. troll gaming
asks on gamespot was your favorite
feature in the game what do you think
first Sean I personally I like being
able to use legs as a weapon something
that you don't often see in video games
my favorite feature was the sort of the
likey I don't know not knowing what to
do in these games is fun like not
knowing the rules not knowing how you
know when the counter was gonna call
them what happens if the first time you
dine you appear in the cave like all
that wonder yeah and I guess the sort of
frustrating thing about playing an alpha
is now keep going that way don't know I
have an idea i'm gonna first time you
die in this game it transports you to a
cave yeah
zombie yes kill yourself sex demons as
the case may be sometimes I am going to
hear and contemplate beauty and suicide
at this let's be honest time kickflip oh
I think you see London inside a cave as
well Oh their projects wouldn't drag me
in there yeah here we go ready for you
need a sex demon all right so you come
to and it's real dark and it's like hey
why don't you just hit l use lighter and
sometimes it's a little little less
little less atmospheric here but uh we
got a dual wield a accent like they're
down there we go it is a dark and here
it started [ __ ] you know it's gonna
happen right it's gonna happen we all
this does he know you're gonna get out
of here scot-free yeah but there's a
bunch of there's a bunch of dead people
well you've collected loads at how many
have you seen them uh I think there are
a hundred and five only seems he's six
in this saves day why would I when you
use my flashlight man whatever at Ned
book chatty asks between Daisy rosston
this which is more better / enjoyable
Sean what do you think four is uh I mean
my favorite game of the bunch is
probably rest hmm but I don't I don't
think this game is quite as far along
enough to compare to Daisy and rust
because those ones have just had so much
more time to iterate you just fall
through the late I don't know if it is
screaming it is very darn oh oh you know
what I might try load it up I think you
fell through the level I think I fell I
don't even know what's going on right
look up look up that's like no table
that's the underside of the table am I
on the ceiling I think we found a
wormhole dang oh my dad I honestly
cannot see ya oh nice work in many ways
that is the most appropriate a demo of
the first you could have nothing
happened and then you fell through the
floor but it was a nice hike wasn't it
beautiful hi
you